hey Thomas Monson you understand you're
trespassing right now right I have an
easement with the previous owner of your
property previous being the operative
word
it was this it's the guy till you either
get back in your nice truck go play okey
[ __ ] somewhere else
I call it looks like mr. Monson hire
some muscle looks that way
he's a friend of mine friend with a big
mouth I hear that a lot
and you probably hear this too more than
I'd like
and you know the grill I'll mow count
three and you're gonna start walking
away
Yeah right to this one I have a lawyer
now - you know the drill
grace how sweet the sound
like
hey youtubers is Charlie got a bunch of
new Logan let's break it down we got to
talk about classic Brown costume there's
a bunch of Legion stuff for the first
episode that's dropping this week and we
got new details on x-men supernova
The Dark Phoenix project there's a new
round of the Logan giveaway it's for
IMAX gift certificates all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything this just shows you how
bad things have gotten so this is in
Texas I think somewhere near the border
close to Mexico but it's set six plus
years after the end of the last x-men
film in there fighting over water
literally that's what this clip is about
this person that Logan's met v of trying
to protect Professor X that they've
taken in with just wants to get water
from this well in the person who owns
the land is getting really pissed off as
trying to drive them off Logan's
response is priceless to like he [ __ ]
the gun he says yeah I hear that a lot
more than I like to just all the times
that he's been shot remember he has the
adamantium skeleton still you see him in
the Amazing Grace part of the clip just
holding his claws that's because he's
gotten so old his regenerative powers
have gotten so weak that it actually
hurts him a lot more now to pop the
claws so yeah he can still eat a bullet
or two he could probably eat a shotgun
blast but it would take him a lot longer
to heal that's why he's showing so many
signs of wear you can see it a little
bit better here when he's crawling on
the ground in the middle of this giant
fight after he's been running around
clawing the hell out of people just
still a beast but so much that old man
Logan persona from the comics you have
to imagine that Wolverine is only
functionally immortal he's not
completely immortal so eventually he
would die of natural causes it would
just take hundreds of times longer than
a normal human it's not quite like
Deadpool's healing factor his healing
factor is almost instantaneous so it's a
little more powerful which is why he
still has the cancer a lot of people
always wondered that if he has the
healing factor why doesn't he look like
a normal person well it's because his
healing factor heals the cancerous cells
from before his X gene was activated so
his healing factor just restores him to
his original state which means that all
the tumors grow back which kind of sucks
speaking of which a lot of you spotted
in Caliban were making
Deadpool jokes because his face does
kind of look like Deadpool face it's a
very old version of Caliban the reason
he's in this movie is because he has the
ability to sense other mutants within a
25-mile radius so either the Reavers are
forcing him to help them hunt down the
rest of mutant kind and track down x-23
and return her to the Weapon X program
or Logan and Professor X try to seek him
out to try and find the other bands of
mutants that have managed to survive all
these purges but he's holding two live
grenades in this picture so this looks
like it's somewhere where the Reavers
have captured him so for those that are
wondering why he's in the movie it's
because the Reavers have been hunting
down and killing x-men that's also what
they did in the comics but if you were
gonna do that you would need someone to
help you find all those mutants normally
you could just go to Professor X in
cerebro but Caliban is the next best
option and he's actually Stephen
Merchant was also in x-men apocalypse is
a much younger version of the character
where apocalypse went to recruit new
mutants to become his horseman so I do
like that they're acknowledging some
x-men history while at the same time
doing their own thing it's within the
x-men universe but this is so far in the
future at any time they make a reference
to comic book things it's really just
gonna be tongue-in-cheek in speaking of
Easter eggs a lot of people were
freaking out when Hugh Jackman posted
this picture and just said the original
in the caption and it was a picture of
Wolverine in his classic brown costume
so people are like oh my god are we
actually gonna see this in the movie
will we see it in the comic book that
x-23 is reading he's wearing the yellow
costume but that doesn't necessarily
guarantee that we'll ever see him wear
that version of the costume but maybe
somebody has a picture of them from a
long time ago and in the picture
Wolverines wearing the costume and
that's how we'll see it but that aside
there might just be a Wolverine action
figure inside the movie but if there's a
comic book about the x-men in the movie
that means that there's also all the
other kind of comic book merchandise
that they make we'll just twist your
head around maybe there are x-men films
inside the x-men films that would be
crazy but next big thing x-men
supernovae so there was a synopsis that
people found that's been known for a
while it might have changed but it
basically says that supernovae will be
Dark Phoenix so I'll read
this gathered together by Professor
Charles Xavier to protect a world that
fears and hates them
the x-men had fought many battles been
on adventures that spanned galaxies
grappled enemies of limitless might but
none of this could prepare them for the
most shocking struggle they would ever
face one of their own members Jean Grey
has gained powers beyond all
comprehension in that power has
corrupted her absolutely now they must
decide if the life of the woman they
cherish is worth the existence of the
entire universe so they just blows your
mind is definitely the Dark Phoenix
storyline but that doesn't mean that
they're still doing that because this
seems like it's a little old so they may
have changed their plans for what the
next x-men movie is going to be it's
still called supernova that's the
working title but that might change a
little so if we get any updates I'll
post a video about it but it just sounds
like Fox is gonna be pretty quiet about
what that project is they're a little
more open about what's going on with new
mutants and Deadpool - just because that
stuff has all been confirmed but the
next big thing later this week Legion
episode 1 is going to drop it's
Wednesday night at 10:00 p.m. in the
United States so be sure to check where
it's airing internationally which
channel it's on it's Fox international
channels so if you live outside the
United States and you watch say like The
Walking Dead that airs on Fox channels
that means that Legion will probably be
on the same channel you would normally
find The Walking Dead on it's Wednesday
night it airs at the same time all over
the world so I'll be posting my video
Thursday morning for that they dropped a
whole bunch more footage around the
Superbowl so I'm gonna play those clips
here it's really trippy
you cannot run and hide from the voices
inside your head
perhaps instead you can just lower the
volume
Legion careers Wednesday on FX so just a
reminder this is gonna be happening
Wednesday night my video will post
Thursday morning for it we can decide
whether or not we want to talk about it
week to week I think it's gonna be
really cool it's only eight episodes so
it's a relatively low time investment I
think it's gonna be really cool though
but there's gonna be a whole bunch more
Logan stuff because there's so much
Superbowl stuff that dropped that I'm
still trying to get through my next
video later tonight will be for that
Justice League preview they had some
pretty big teasers inside of that so
I'll explain what's going on in that but
there are links in the description for
all the Super Bowl stuff that I've done
in case you missed any of the videos
giveaway time Eric wall you're the new
Logan giveaway winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details
there's a new round of this video I'll
just announce the winner when I post
that Legion episode one video on
Thursday while you wait for that you can
click here for all the Guardians trailer
stuff and you can click here for
stranger things season 2 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you in the next video
you